now to new details on a horrific crime
in California this one in which a former
police officer allegedly catfished a
teenager and then murdered three members
of her family thousands of miles from
his home the alleged killer was shot
dead in a confrontation with local
sheriff's deputies Errol Barnett has
more on this story
this guy's a monster he's a predator
28-year-old Austin Lee Edwards resigned
as a Virginia state trooper late last
month according to police he drove
cross-country to meet a 15 year old girl
who lived at home with her mother and
grandparents he developed a relationship
with her there might have been an
exchange of texts maybe phone calls on
La station KCBS reports a neighbor
called 9-1-1 after she sold the suspect
wearing a trench coat and a mask arguing
with a crying Barefoot girl believed to
be the 15 year old before she got into
Edward's car
a fire at her home started shortly
thereafter but the bodies of Mark and
Sherry winick and 38 year old Brooke
winick found in the entryway we believe
at this point that this suspect was the
only one involved in the murders and in
setting the fire later that day deputies
Tracked Down Edwards in the desert
fatally shooting the suspect after an
exchange of gunfire it's believed
Edwards was grooming the teen by
pretending to be someone else online
online catfishing is very common
children do not understand
how dangerous it can be to talk to a
stranger
online cyber safety cups Clayton
Cranford warns parents should be
vigilant they should turn on parental
controls and at night that device does
not belong in a child's bedroom the CB
cbus mornings I'm Errol Barnett